Scott Bay's choppers will be here to
pick up the team in 15 hours it's an
early start this morning and we've got
to break the camp down but not everyone
is ready yes I mean science in in the
Dry Valleys he's gone really well we've
knocked out pretty much all of our
sample sites except for two of us that's
Kurt and I are gonna go up the mountain
over there and hit off the last ample
sight whilst the rest of the team down
here it takes care of pulling together
the camp it's gonna be a feely long day
yeah science may only take 30 minutes an
hour maybe but four hours of walking to
get to that site right let's do this
the Dry Valleys are done like anyplace
else on earth every step you take is
actually an exceptionally unique one
you're walking in an area that has never
been experienced by another human being
you kind of get completely captivated
but at the same time your body feels
incredibly tired the impact from walking
hits you yeah that's pretty tough stop
for a second the mummified feel actually
pretty pretty good condition
yeah that's wrap it this valley is 30
miles from the ocean and it's so cold
and dry that dead organic tissue can be
preserved for decades or longer you know
this this guy's probably been sitting
here for a couple of hundred years you
know they've come a long way to get here
these guys are not very good at
navigating when there's a storm when
they get lost and just they continue to
walk until they they die the dryness of
the system will slowly dehydrate them
and then they'll just shrink and become
mummies the question is really is how
they got here because it's really
difficult to get from the ocean into
this valley it's one of these dry Valley
mysteries
move on to our next States still got
quite a lot to go